[Música]
nuestras organizaciones están obsoletas
y algunos de ustedes pueden pensar es
cierto no es cierto la empresa o la
organización en la que yo trabajo es muy
innovadora y siempre estamos
reinventando los yo les pregunto esa
innovación es hacia fuera o hacia
adentro tiene que ver con los productos
y servicios que le están ofreciendo a la
gente o tiene que ver con esa estructura
interna de la organización como trabajan
juntos
bueno lo cierto es que nuestro mundo
cambió y cambió mucho y nuestras
organizaciones no tanto
cuando vi este libro muriendo por un
salario que es esto está terriblemente
mal en la forma en que estamos
trabajando juntos en este libro el autor
presenta las ideas de la doctora nuria
chinchilla de la universidad de navarra
y ella cuenta que las organizaciones y
las empresas siempre en el afán que
tenemos por alcanzar objetivos por
cumplir metas vamos generando impactos
algunos positivos y otros negativos
negativas por ejemplo donde conocemos
impactos ambientales pero también
generan impactos sociales y culturales
que tienen una gran consecuencia
negativa en el bienestar de la gente
y a esto ella le llama contaminación
social
ustedes sabían que una persona que
trabaja muchísimo pero que no tiene
capacidad de decisión en su trabajo
tiene más chance de morirse un factor
contaminación social el estrés esa que
es como la enfermedad del siglo verdad
que la causa principalmente
el trabajo más contaminación social de
nuestras organizaciones 4 de cada 5
personas cree que su organización es
completamente obsoleta y tiene que
cambiar
y por qué porque trabajamos de 8 de la
mañana a 5 de la tarde más en entornos
con baja satisfacción laboral con baja
motivación y con altísima desconfianza
en la gerencia en los líderes
qué pasa cuando usted está enamorado de
algo enamorada y luego así con ojitos de
corazoncito cómo nos comportamos le
ponemos atención nos digamos que le
gusta que no le gusta un buen pico así
teníamos a esa persona verdad ahora qué
pasa si esa misma persona
yo la veo con ojos de indiferencia
la actitud cambia como me comporto lo
que hago para esa persona es diferente
de la misma forma que como sentimos o
vemos a una persona cambia como actuamos
con ella también la manera en que
pensamos sobre las personas al día
nuestras organizaciones y cómo
trabajamos entonces usted piensa que las
personas son vagabundos les pone un
coordinador otro coordinador otro sujeto
jefe y un montón de gente que los esté
controlando para que trabajen verdad si
usted piensa que las personas son
deshonestas qué hacemos le ponemos
candado a todo y les ponemos relojes en
las puertas para que marquen entrada y
salida
si pensamos que la gente solo le
interesa el poder que hacemos
agarramos ese poder y lo concentramos
para que nadie tenga acceso a él
y en definitiva así yo creo que la gente
no es capaz de tomar decisiones entonces
no los dejo tomar decisiones y lo triste
es que nos hemos ido acostumbrando a
vivir ya trabajar en este tipo
organizaciones que ven hacia la gente y
este es un tipo de organización que
surgió para otra era donde no se
necesitaba que nadie fuera innovador que
nadie propusiera ideas que nadie se
saliera de la norma nada más que usted
pudiera repetir una misma cosa una y
otra y otra y otra vez pero ahora
vivimos en otra era y esa brecha entre
lo que estamos viviendo y lo que es
posible es gigante
no será que ya es hora de actualizarlos
un poquito así como le hacemos la
actualización del sistema operativo a la
computadora bueno hagámosle una
actualización del sistema operativo a
nuestras organizaciones
esto no lo digo sólo yo hay un montón de
investigadores que se han dedicado a
estudiar cómo trabajamos juntos entre
ellos fotos aymer de lehman o ken wilber
con su teoría integral o uno de mis
autores favoritos de los últimos años
feder y la lux se lo recomiendo en su
libro reinventa las organizaciones él
cuenta una serie de historias de
organizaciones que se han atrevido a
cambiar estructuras y a pensar diferente
de la gente ya trabajar diferente pero
algo que estos tres autores tienen en
común es la idea de equipar a cada etapa
de evolución de la humanidad ha surgido
un nuevo tipo organización vean qué
curioso y una forma muy bonita de verlos
a través de colores entonces les voy a
contar así para que veamos el recorrido
histórico digamos que hace
diez mil años nuestros primeros
ancestros que empezaron a crear las
primeras tribus y organizarse con un
macho alfa fuerte poderoso que nos
protegía de los salvajes como ese lobo
de la manada así que ese tipo de
organización que estaba basada en la
violencia y la agresividad en la fuerza
pero que es un poco inestable hernán aún
hoy este tipo de organización que la
organización llamada roja existe tenemos
pandillas cárteles de la droga mafias
que actúan con estas mismas reglas hoy
hace cinco mil años la humanidad empezó
a necesitar más bien un poquito más de
orden en tanto caos y empezó a crear
instituciones más rígidas más
estructuradas donde usted más bien se
enfocaba en la tradición en repetir las
cosas en una práctica aquí y que todo el
mundo la pudiera repetir las
organizaciones ámbar o amarillas y uno
de los ejemplos más tradicionales y que
existe hasta hoy también el ejército
o la iglesia o las instituciones
gubernamentales
y hace 500 años a la humanidad le empezó
a importar más la ciencia a la industria
la complejidad y entonces surgieron las
organizaciones naranja que es como lo
que veríamos hoy las corporaciones que
siguen siendo estructuradas con aquellas
pirámides que todos conocemos muy bien
pero que es un poquito más eficiente es
como es el relojito suizo que cada pieza
funciona en perfecta sincronía
o hace 50 años más bien empezaron a
surgir los modelos enfocados en valores
en el propósito en donde la empresa se
ve como una familia
y lo más importante es eso las
relaciones la colaboración a eso se le
llama empresas verdes
y entonces hemos ido avanzando como
humanidad y para cada etapa de evolución
nuestra también ha surgido una nueva y
un nuevo tipo organización y en esta
nueva etapa en que estamos hoy cuál es
este tipo de organización
nos va a contar una anécdota de mi
adolescencia cuando yo era adolescente
trabajé por muchos años como voluntaria
con una organización que llamábamos el
móvil y el móvil y lograba algo que
parece imposible y es organizar
adolescentes entonces nosotros toda la
semana nos reuníamos para aprender sobre
valores para aprender su liderazgo no
sólo eso sino que hacíamos talleres a
organizábamos campamentos hacíamos
activas al aire libre y todo eso pasaba
no solo en mi barrio que de hecho estos
eran mis compañeros de barrio san
antonio sanz parados hace 20 años sino
que pasaba en mi barrio y pasaba en 15 ó
20 barrios en diferentes partes del país
simultáneamente sin un jefe
nadie nos decía que hacer teníamos y
algunas autoridades que nos apoyaban
para que nosotros pudiéramos tomar
decisiones pero básicamente todo pasaba
porque nos organizábamos nosotros
y esa es ese tipo de organización tener
un impacto en los barrios y en los
jóvenes que iban al grupo y en nosotros
mismos que perdura hasta hoy a muchos de
ellos los considero entre mis mejores
amigos y la gente más cara que conocido
en una organización diferente sin la
estructura que estamos acostumbradas
como funcionó
por tres cosas que creo que es una
fundamental de la primera la confianza
confianza en que todos y todas somos
capaces de grandes cosas
segundo propósito un propósito común un
objetivo común que teníamos que hacía
que cualquier decisión que cualquiera
tomara en cualquier parte del país está
enfocada en eso
y tercero descentralización
no sólo estábamos distribuidos en costa
rica sino que el poder no estaba en una
persona y en un grupito todos podíamos
tomar decisiones
y entonces lleva este ejemplo y pienso
si a nosotros nos funcionó significa que
está pasando están surgiendo nuevos
tipos de organizaciones con diferentes
reglas a las que conocemos
y ahora que estamos en la era de la
cuarta revolución industrial la era de
las tecnologías exponenciales lo más
lógico es que si están surgiendo estas
nuevas prácticas y gente queriendo hacer
las cosas diferente aprovechen estas
tecnologías jacques y hagamos que sea
todavía de mayor impacto y una de las
tecnologías que para mí es más
interesante que nos puede ayudar más a
trabajar juntos de formas diferentes es
una tecnología que se llama block change
y blocks en lo que nos permite es
conectar a las personas de una forma que
nunca antes lo habíamos hecho nos
permite intercambiar valor entre las
personas sin necesidad de un
intermediario nos permite tomar
decisiones colectivamente sin necesidad
de una autoridad central y sobre todo
nos permite confiar unos en otros porque
yo confiaba en mis colegas del móvil
porque sabía que habían demostrado con
el tiempo que lo que decían lo hacían
que eran transparentes en definitiva que
yo podía confiar en ellos
pero cuando cuando estoy trabajando con
personas que no conozco cómo puedo
confiar bueno block chay nos permite
tener información transparente segura y
poder confiar en las personas aunque no
las conozcamos de cerquita y entonces
surgen organizaciones que no dependen de
un lugar físico como el kit city market
city es una plataforma de transporte
colaborativo como las que conocemos
verdad que la gente se comparte los
carros y se llevan de un lugar a otro en
donde los usuarios los clientes y los
conductores son co dueños de la
plataforma no hay una corporación detrás
que se deja todas las ganancias sino que
ellos deciden cómo funcionan qué tarifas
van a definir cómo van a dar el servicio
y lo más interesante es que tienen una
cripto moneda una moneda propia de la
plataforma que se llama a quito king y
todos los intercambios entre ellos pasan
con esa moneda lo que hace que sea súper
seguro
otro ejemplo es tímido es tímido es la
primera red social en block change hoy
puede enredar sitios suscribirse y
empezar a crear contenido cada vez que
usted crea contenido en streaming y
alguien le da tome surf hay que ver que
no sólo se gana su like sino que se gana
una recompensa en steam dollars y sting
dólares es una moneda propia de la
plataforma y entonces si mi contenido
muy buen y recibe muchos likes mi
recompensa una grande y si alguien más
se interesó en mi contenido y comentó y
también recibió un like también nos
tiene una recompensa porque contribuyó a
que ese contenido fuera mejor y entonces
todos estamos conectados con el objetivo
de crear buen contenido de calidad y
compartirlo y estamos recibiendo una
recompensa por ese esfuerzo que estamos
dando obispal dispárales una plataforma
que estamos creando con tu cómic con mis
colegas que permite que cualquier
comunidad cualquier grupo de personas
que tiene un objetivo ambiental y social
común pueda crear sus propias cripto
monedas o monedas virtuales y entonces
atender esos problemas y juntarse y
trabajar juntos cómo funcionaría vamos a
imaginar que todos nosotros somos del
mismo barrio
y vivimos en una comunidad que es
atravesada por un río imagínense un río
que no está muy limpio
eso no es difícil imaginárselo y nuestro
objetivo como comunidad es cuidar de
serviu queremos que esté bien que
sabemos que representa salud para todos
cada vez que uno de nosotros hace algo
para contribuir a que servido esté mejor
se gana 10 bío monedas que la moneda que
estamos creando para nuestra plataforma
y cada vez que usted va y siembra un
árbol a la orilla del río se gana 20 mil
monedas
y usted también eso también entonces
todos con esas monedas podemos ir a una
supermercado a una panadería a la
peluquería del barrio y usar estas
monedas para tener acceso a productos y
servicios de la comunidad y ellos
participan esos empresarios porque
participan porque también son parte la
comunidad quieren crear ese río y
también puedes usar sus monedas para
tener acceso a otros productos y
servicios como hubiéramos hecho
tradicionalmente muy gramos cuidados y
si hubiéramos hecho un comité y otro y
buscar fondos y hacer un proyecto tal
vez esperar en la muni y pasan los años
y no pasa nada
aquí siri es tímido y de espaldas son
ejemplos de este nuevo tipo organización
que está emergiendo y una nueva forma de
colaborar juntos de estar motivados
porque estamos haciendo cosas que nos
importan y además estamos recibiendo
recompensas que nos permiten continuar y
tener una mejor calidad de vida
y en esta nueva etapa de evolución que
estamos la palabra clave es comunidad a
estas iniciativas se les llama
plataformas cooperativas organizaciones
colaborativas online pero cuando eso se
funde con block change le llamamos
organizaciones autónomas
descentralizadas o dados por sus siglas
en inglés imagínense que cada barrio de
costa rica tuvieron ha dado y entonces
pudiéramos resolver nuestros problemas
de formas más creativas y en lugar de
tener diez monedas podríamos tener de
sant para colones y en desamparados
todos los vecinos nos ponemos de acuerdo
que lo que más nos importa es cuidar la
limpieza de nuestros barrios o la
seguridad la educación y todos
colaboramos para que eso pase y
recibimos recompensas por eso incluso
las personas que usualmente están fuera
del sistema la persona desempleada por
ejemplo podría dignamente ganarse su
sustento ciento siendo orgullosa de
colaborar con su comunidad o podríamos
tenerlos colby coins y entonces aquí en
calvi decimos de vamos a promover
innovación y vamos a crear porque coins
cada vez que alguien propone una idea
innovadora
llegar a colby coins y la gente que
tiene condiciones se pone junta y hacen
proyectos juntos y los llevan a cabo o
incluso invitamos a los clientes a los
usuarios a proponer ideas y también
serán a sus colecciones que los pueden
intercambiar por tiempo de aire y
entonces estamos resolviendo el problema
de la innovación de motivar a la gente
de que estén felices y al mismo tiempo
estamos atrayendo nuevos usuarios al
sistema
y entonces no es muy difícil imaginar
que de repente tenemos muchos dados y
podemos ser parte de muchos al mismo
tiempo unas aquí a nivel local en mi
barrio otros a nivel internacional con
gente de todo el mundo que piensa y
quiere lo mismo que yo
se imaginan imaginan que costa rica
puede hacer un líder mundial en la
creación de estados tenemos todo lo que
se necesita toda la tecnología la parte
social podemos hacer que costa rica sea
no sólo reconocida como un país verde
que combate la contaminación ambiental
sino que además podemos tomar las
decisiones hoy que nos lleven a hacer
que costa rica sea un país total y
completamente libre de contaminación
social
[Aplausos]